welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
aka the guy who's tall stark and
handsome
in this video we're breaking down the
craziest theories surrounding one
division
the wonderful world of west view gets
weirder every week and so far there's
been several theories that could
indicate exactly what's going on
we'll be discussing how it may be a show
within a show
why what we're watching might not even
be the main mcu timeline
who agnes is nightmare and a lot more if
you love the video 3 000 then please hit
the thumbs up button
and make sure you subscribe to the show
if you're invested
invested in the channel anyway the first
thing i want to talk about is how one
division could potentially be doing an
inception on everyone by making a show
within a show within a show
i was first sent this theory by katie
lee and since then it's something i've
started to think about the more and more
i've watched the series
now what this means is that potentially
both the one division sitcom and sword
moments
are happening in their own tv show that
we are watching this would explain why
we're watching
sword rather than shield and also why
the characters in it
very much fit the archetypes of cop
procedurals
we've got a jag-off boss who initially
seemed like a nice guy
but the more that we've got to know him
the more we know that he's a
terrorist as in he terrorizes the good
plans
by being a buffoon there's the nerdy
signs sidekick who helps to do all the
tech stuff behind the scenes
and also the fun but bumbling partner
who's seen in jimmy woo
now why this could be a possibility is
because of some of the imagery that's
appeared in both the show and the
apparent outside world
hexagons are a big symbol in the city of
west view
and these seem to be unique to the
sitcoms however they've also appeared in
hayward's office in the layout of his
plaques
his carpet pattern also had these
present and
at this point they seem to have been
included for a specific reason
another detail could be seen in the
coffee cups that jimmy was carrying
and the pattern on these seemed very
similar to the one that's shown in the
credits at the end
the pattern was also seen in geraldine
or other monikers dressed in the 60s
episode
and if we look at the credits we can see
several objects that have appeared in
the show itself
shout outs hacks dogma who pointed out
that this likely means that the hex is
technology based rather than magic
and i will be discussing another theory
of his in an upcoming video
to do keep an eye out must broke it to
squeeze his stinking sister to death or
what
there was also a big continuity error
across the episodes that could hint at
wonder actually controlling what we see
meaning that we may be in the show too
oh no
she's gone she didn't belong here oh she
left honey
she had to rush home now this is such a
strange change and it seems like they
are purposely lacing the series with a
lot of hidden details
even down to its recaps this shows that
wonder is literally controlling the
perception of absolutely everything
and altering things after the fact
similar to how she did when she reversed
time
now the fact that the hex can expand may
also mean that it already has before
unbeknownst to those actually inside of
it this would mean that everyone is
trapped within a reality that they can't
see taste or touch
and it's a bit like the matrix but it's
one division and it's inception at the
same time
now another theory that is in the same
vein as this is that we are actually
watching a wonder in an alternate
reality
and the show is that versions villain
origin story
as we know from end game alternate
versions of characters
and paths can be taken though cap
returned all of the infinity stones back
to their specific places
there's no telling what this could have
done on a grand scale we know for
definite that in the 2014 reality that
the avengers went to an endgame
that that version of thanos was
completely wiped out along with all his
forces
that will have drastically altered the
timeline and likely have meant that the
snap never occurred
now whilst this isn't the case in the
show steve also took loki's staff during
2012
and though he may have returned it this
could have caused a butterfly effect
that changed how wonder and pietro were
given their powers
those things might be completely
different and due to the pietro coming
across from the fox universe
we know that it's possible to journey
into alternate dimensions
thus the wonder that we are watching
might go through the multiverse itself
and end up facing off against the one we
know and love in the main timeline
this would mean that elizabeth olsen
could play both the villain and good guy
and doctor strange too
and as we know it's called in the
multiverse of madness
therefore the pair being brought across
the multiverse to face off against each
other
would make for a big movie but i guess
uh we'll just have to wait and find out
now one thing that's actually in the
realms of possibility because let's be
honest though those other theories are a
bit stupid
is that sort of attempting to weaponize
vision in order to create their own
ultron
after this snap it's clear that things
became tough and though it was against
his will
vision could clearly make a powerful
weapon even in death
ultron was a bad first attempt like me
before my parents had my little sister
but desperate times call for desperate
measures and perhaps tony's plan to put
a suit of armor around the world
was picked up after the avengers lost a
cataracts is of course a medical eye
condition
and this being labeled as one of tyler
hayward's operations
could be a play on the word vision and
mean that they are attempting to create
his opposite
vision's personality is a complex
layering of the mind stone
tony stark bruce banner and of course
ultron
and should they tweak his mind properly
they could definitely unlock tony's
protocols as well as the ultron system
when wanda goes to the sword facility we
can see vision's body being torn apart
and experimented on
and she likely found out about this and
went to rescue him aware of the issues
it could cause should he get out
heywood may have placed a tracking
device in him and this is how he's able
to follow him through the hex
now i actually don't think that wonder
took the body with her
as we actually never see this happen and
the camera cuts out before it
kind of feels like it may be revealed
that it's still in the compound
and that the one in the bubble is the
one that she's created herself
but that's a long shot i'm just
exploring the other possibilities
cataracts could also mean something
that's anti-vision so perhaps hayward is
developing
a weapon to take him down should he ever
need to another thing that i'm slowly
seeing hints towards is that heywood is
actually ultron himself
masquerading as a government official if
you watch the animated show avengers
assemble
then you may remember the character
marsh who is very much the hayward
archetype
in the end he was revealed to be ultron
in disguise and the similarities between
the pair are quite striking
there was actually a sketch posted
online recently
that showed what looked like ultron
hiding beneath the shell of a man
and being ripped open by magneto in
reference to hill line in house of m
wonder said no more hiding and though
it's a bit of a jump to say this will
definitely be in the show
it's something i'd absolutely love to
see boss logic did do a little eye emoji
to it
and if you've been following our
breakdowns and you'll know that he was
recently in talks with kevin feige
about doing marvel art work and actually
posted an image of magneto
that looked like he was bursting out the
hex this is all very tenuously linked at
the moment
but hayward's closeness division could
be hinting at something else
going on beneath the surface now lastly
i want to talk about the overall villain
of the show
i think things are definitely pointing
towards agnes
though i originally thought that she
might be agatha harkness actually think
now that she might be an amalgamation of
several characters
including harkness mephisto and
nightmare
comic book movies have been known to do
this in the past and we saw that ducard
and raz al-ghul and batman begins where
two characters combined into one
in the mcu crimson dynamo and whiplash
was sort of mixed together to make
whiplash in iron man 2 and it's
definitely within the realms of
possibility to mush people together
throughout the show we have had several
nods to this being a nightmare
and the word was dropped twice in
episode six there has been a lot of
hints towards the devil as well such as
the devil in the details
bermuda which is home of the devil's
triangle the new jersey devil
the two kids being called the devil's
spawn halloween
and a lot more agonists stated that her
and ralph's anniversary was on the 2nd
of june
which is the day that the salem witch
trials started and she's also used words
like
charmed which is a witch show so she's
giving it away i'm telling you when the
children grew up she was present both
times
and also poisoned their dog probably as
a way to make them grow once more
but don't tell john wick please now
actus was also willing to throw moniker
under the bus
perhaps in an attempt to get vision and
wanted to turn on her
so she wouldn't be able to unearth her
plans in the car scene she did implicate
wonder as being behind it all
however this reminded me a lot of the
scene in episode 3
in which he implicated monica norm also
stated that
she was doing this all which could be a
nod to her
and the fact that agnes is the only one
to mention wonder by name
makes me think that she's trying to get
vision to leave too before he uncovers
what's going on
or she may be trying to turn him against
his wife so that they take each other
out and then she can steal their kids
whose powers have now manifested which
not the best valentine's day weak
present is it vision talking to your
wife like that
i think something is definitely going on
with her and imagine that we will find
out the truth very soon
the broach that she has has three
characters on it and
if she is a combination of those that we
mentioned before then this could also be
a cool
easter egg anyway that's our video over
i won't subject you to any more torture
and obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the theories so make sure
you comment below and let me know
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
draw on the 28th of february
in which we're giving away three copies
of the marvel phase 3 4k box set to our
subscribers
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the theories the winners of
last month's competition are on screen
right now
so that's you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of episode 6 which will be
linked on screen right now
we went over the entire thing top to
bottom so it's definitely worth checking
out if you want to know more
by the way thank you for sitting through
the video it's not like you had anything
else to do though is it let's be let's
be honest you loser
i mean paul you've been the best i'll
see you next time you take care yourself
peace